if I could redesign the world I would
make sure that I didn't try and take on
everything I tried to make sure that I
focused on very specific actions that
would make a difference first of all I
would address the issues of
infrastructure in developing countries
there's a really very big missing part
of the actions that really get people's
hands dirty things have been in
development have been intellectualized
to such a point that nobody thinks about
the management that actually people have
to put in place for example our own
organization riders for health looks at
transport and the management of
transport the health work reaching
healthcare out to rural communities in
Africa and those are the issues I would
address but I think that focus and
looking up the pieces of management in
developing countries that have been
neglected or where I would start